- I hear you play music by ear.
- Well, it's weird because you know,
there's this condition called synesthesia
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- where you can sort of
like your wires are crossed
- Yeah yeah.
- and your sensory pathways
are sort of mixed up.
And so some people can see music.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I don't necessarily,
I sort of do that where
whenever I hear a song,
it's almost like these little
Lego shapes in my mind.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So that's how I remember arrangement.
That's how I remember composition.
It becomes a visual
thing for me to rely on
because I can't read music.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I wish I could.
I mean, I really wish that
I spent more time learning
more about music, but both
of my parents were musicians.
My father was a classically
trained flautist.
My mother sang in singing groups.
- [Kelly] Oh my God it was destiny.
- [Dave] It's kind... I do believe in DNA.
- Yeah yeah.
- I really do believe in this
thing that it's passed down.
- And behavioral, you're
around it all the time as well.
- Yeah. And so I just
kinda figured it out.
- Yeah. I gotta be honest with you.
I actually learned singing
and I learned harmony,
all of that without sheet
music. I was like, you, I,
I could somehow feel it.
Mine was a feeling, like I could feel
- Right
- where it was and place it, but my,
I was way better at like hearing it
and doing it rather than reading.
- Yeah its, uh,
And when I grew up in Virginia
and my mother was a public school teacher.
- [Kelly] Oh mine was too.
- No way.
- Yeah, oh our mothers
have talked. That's right.
Our mothers, because
your mother did the book.
I think, I feel like she...
- [Dave] Yes.
- ...yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- My mother wrote a book
called From "Cradle to Stage".
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah, yeah
- And it was all about...
- Yeah
I just remembered that.
- ...mothers and musicians.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, it was really cool.
- But both of our momma's are teachers.
- She interviewed like 20
different mothers of musicians.
And, um, what she found were
these really clear parallels,
like most of these people;
Dr. Dre and Pharrell and Miranda Lambert
and people like that,
they sort of discovered
music in this specific window
of time in between the
ages of about 10 and 13,
- Yeah
- Where like identity
and independence sort
of intersect right there.
- Uh huh.
- And if you're a kid
and have any sort of musical inclination
uh, or an instrument falls in your lap,
then most likely you're going
to become a musician because
that becomes a part of your identity.
Um, and so when I was young,
like I didn't have a drum set,
I would set up pillows on the floor...
- Yeah.
- ...and just put on my favorite records
and play along to them.
- Yeah.
- Um, because I could hear the
difference between like, oh,
that's a kick drum, that's
a snare, that's a symbol.
Then it was just a matter of like
the physicality of figuring it out.
- [Kelly] Yeah
- So
- [Kelly] That's innovative
- So yeah, it was cool.
Like they didn't have much.
- My instrument was free. So
I just practiced in my room.
- Thank God you did. You know what I mean?
I started on keys and I
was like, this is not my,
this is not my thing.
And I, I, I loved singing, though,
but I did have my own studio in my closet.
- I took one drum lesson.
- [Kelly] You did?
- My mother used to take
me to this jazz club
in Washington, DC on Sundays.
And they had this jazz workshop
thing and there was this
house drummer, his name is Lenny Robinson.
And he was such a bad-ass. I
mean, I was like 15 years old.
Learned to play on the pillows.
And I saw this guy, I'm like,
I'm going to ask him to give me lessons.
So he's was like 30 bucks an
hour. I'm like, all right.
So he comes over to the
house and I had the drum set
and he sits down. He does
this crazy jazz solo thing.
He goes, let me see what you can do.
And I'm like ladadada,
and then he goes, okay, first thing,
you're holding your sticks backwards.
(laughter)
And he's got me on this practice
pad kind of doing this for
30 bucks an hour. I was like,
I can't afford to become a drummer.
- [Kelly] I can't afford...
- Like a million dollars.
(Laughter)
- I was like $30 an hour. Oh my God.
So wait. So your new book, I love this.
First, congratulations.
- Thank you.
- Number one.
That's amazing.
And it's called Storyteller.
- [Dave] Yes.
- [Kelly] So why did you,
why pick now to write that?
I feel like everybody in the limelight,
they always want you to write
a book and I'm nervous about
it, but you.
- You should do it, because it's fun..
- I love how you've done it
though. You've done it...
- Well, here's what happened.
So, you know, Fu Fighters
have been a band for 26 years.
At this point.
(cheering)
And like, we spent the last
quarter of a century on tour.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
So last year, when everything shut down,
I had nothing to do. And I'm such a spazz.
I was like, what am I going to do?
I got nothing to do. I can't have nothing.
- [Kelly] Where do I put
this creative energy?
- So you know what I did, I
started an Instagram page.
(cheering)
Like my first. Yay,
Instagram. I had no idea.
I was like wait, how's this work?
And so instead of taking pictures
of like myself in a thong
in the mirror, I was like,
how about I'll just write stories.
So I started this Instagram
page called Dave's true stories.
And I was writing these little
short stories about like,
- Pleas tell me this is a gif somewhere.
- That's how I...
- Jamming with like Bowie,
Jamming with Prince...
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- ...and all these crazy things that have
happened in my life.
Once I realized like,
oh, this pandemic thing,
this might take a while. I'm like, well,
maybe now's time to write a book.
So, uh, I had this list
of all these stories
I was going to write for
the Instagram page and I,
like short stories.
And I just took that list
and gave it to my editor.
And I said, you pick what
you want me to write.
So she'd say, all right,
write about that car crash
when you were a kid,
like boom, 5,000 words,
write about, uh, joining
Nirvana, boom, 5,000 words.
So I was writing these short stories.
- [Kelly] Mm.
- It's almost like making a record.
So, you know,
you go into the studio
and you have songs...
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- and you start recording
and then an album starts taking shape.
And then you're like, okay,
this is the first song.
This is the last song.
- And then something you
thought was gonna be on there
doesn't make it,
but then something surprises you.
- Yes, and you you start to
realize like what you have
and what you don't have.
But it was the same way as I
was writing these short stories
until finally we put it together.
So there was an arc, uh,
from beginning to end.
And it was really, it
was really rewarding.
Both of my parents were also writers.
My father was a speech
writer and a journalist.
My mother was a creative writing teacher.
So it came naturally, but it was fun.
And you discover a lot about
yourself while you're doing it.
- I know, well, yeah, maybe that's,
I'm not ready for that kind of therapy.
(laughter)
- I'm in between therapists right now.
- I'm actually seeing one
and we haven't made it there.
- Right.
Um, no, it is true though.
I feel like a lot of people
always want to know, you know,
behind the scenes, but like,
I don't know that you really
do. You know what I'm saying?
Like some of it. It's like, mm, let's just
leave it.
- Well, you know, think of it this way.
It doesn't necessarily have to
be specific or informational
or, uh, practical or logistic.
You can write about like a
much more general emotional
picture
- [Kelly] Like a broader...
- of what it's like to be you.
- Yeah.
- Right. So you don't have to talk about.
- And I don't mean that.
I just mean like the road,
they always want the road too,
you know, and you're like, no you don't.
- Well, this is,
this is one of the things
that there were certain,
there were certain things I,
I knew what people wanted me to write.
- [Kelly] Mm hmm.
- And so, because I knew
that's what was expected,
I kind of took this detour around it.
And rather than write something specific,
I wrote about the core of
it was much more emotional
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- in general so that people can relate.
- That's cool though that is
kind of therapeutic for you
though as well while
doing it. That's cool.